it's caught mechanis everyone hello
hello good crowd today are we on are we
on the videos up here no I'm gonna stand
awkwardly live on the internet for a
while how about that there we go
fantastic hey guys really quick big
round of applause for a Jake and Paul
for him seeing this thing right it's you
know it's not every day you get you know
charismatic people able to keep a crowd
entertained while the rest of us blabble
on about technical matters all day
I am Colt McAnlis hopefully my bald
attenuation comes before me by the way
really quick before we talk because this
is sort of the first talk I've done
since the pirate talk how many people
have seen my pirate talk round of
applause give a round of applause the
people on the screen can hear that
doesn't so and the reason I ask that is
I've been I've been approached by like
six people today like hey what are you
doing today like like it's today like
national speak like a Carney day or
something like what do you do and I have
to tell you the story like after after
the pirate talk there was a serious memo
sent between my managers like he's not
gonna do something crazy at dev summit
is he like and they were like checking
the schedule like no no it's just
national hello day he can't screw that
up so anyhow hey guys thanks your time
today thanks for listening so far I know
that lunch is on the horizon I'm gonna
try to keep you entertained for the next
30 minutes here really perf matters yes
round of applause for perfmatters you
follow this use this it was uh it was a
little weird having Linus come up here
and be like perf is everything and I'm
like oh crap I didn't work on my slides
that well so hopefully today we can move
through it uh I've said this before I'll
say this a million times today we're
gonna be talking about tech tooling
techniques for the performance ninja if
you see anything that inspires you and
these fact any statistic you didn't know
go to your social media outlet of choice
put perfmatters on it send it out today
keep the discussion going there's been a
I mean a year ago think about a year ago
we didn't even have mobile performance
tooling right like that wasn't a thing
and in a year we've actually sort of
built this community of angry angry web
developers who want better performance
on the web and really that's what today
is a
because I think we can all sort of agree
that mobile is all that matters right
now if you're not spending 90% of your
time optimizing your mobile website for
the next five billion humans that are
going to be coming on the web you're
kind of wasting your time so let's all
just come together big deep breath in my
web site is slow on mobile I accept it
come on everyone say no nobody okay
that's fine that's right something out
it's a step you'll get there don't worry
it took me a little time I lost my hair
it comes through really mobile is all
that matters and performance hasn't been
good on mobile and I think we all need
to be very blunt about that right and I
think one of the reasons is this I love
this quote by Ilya he said this in a
blog post a while ago what you can
measure you can optimize and this is
really sort of a telling thing right
because if you think about it we really
haven't had the ability to measure
anything in the mobile web again this
time last year we didn't have the
concept of being able to get data of a
webpage running on a mobile device but
thankfully today with the help of like a
DB extension and chrome dev tools we
actually have the ability to load a
website on a mobile device and actually
get the information back into chrome dev
tools so you can get the same power of
your debugging on your desktop and
actually see the performance
characteristics now this is good and bad
it's good because you have this power
it's bad that everyone's starting to
know about this so if your website is
slow there's kind of no more excuses
sorry actually if someone come to my
desk one day they're like wait a minute
wait a minute like we have this power so
why are websites still slow yeah it's
the Internet buddy so once you get the
ability to actually go through this
process and actually get these powerful
tools giving you the information that
you need it's worth pointing out that
that's not enough right so for those of
you who aren't in this sort of like
repetitive loop of performance
optimization you need to understand that
there's three steps three steps to
performance tooling all right and it
starts at the basic form which is go get
data you have to figure out someone says
hey it's slow you got to go figure out
why right so you have to go use dev
tools collect as much information and
this usually ends up being some sort of
like huge sheet of floating-point
numbers and this actually goes into
stage two a huge sheet of floating-point
numbers really kind of sucks no one
wants that because it doesn't tell you
anything this goes into number two which
is you have to gather insight from that
sheet of
numbers you have to figure out wait a
minute we're seeing all of these
waterfall characteristics and it's
pointing at this piece of data over here
that's the insight our site is slow
because we have too many megabytes on
the wire that's causing six second load
times that's why we're about to go
bankrupt woe is me right of course these
are the easy parts chrome dev tools can
really help you get far enough along in
this the really hard part is stage three
and anyone who in here who's dealt with
this realizes that the third one which
is action is the hard part this is where
you take all the numbers and all the
insight and you go wait a minute it's
because we have this five megabyte gif
animating on our main page that we can't
do this and you have to go over to the
designers and the artist and you say I
need this removed and they go nope round
of applause if that's happen to you
yeah so yeah I got to keep you guys
awake before lunch gets here like the
one guy in the back is like sandwiches
this is really the tough part and
probably the most important part of this
loop though is actually repeating it
more times than not what you're going to
find is that your website does not have
a single performance problem but it has
a plethora of performance problems
uncovering one perf problem and fixing
it is not enough because chances are I
was hiding something else and once
you've unturned that stone you realize
oh wait a minute we've got an even
bigger problem that we need to fight
below it now once you sort of realize
that you're gonna have to continually go
through this process of gather insight
action repeat gather inside action you
start getting a sense that the the world
is not that easy right and what we're
going to talk about today is only the
gather in insight parts you can go argue
the action parts with your web designers
later so when you're doing this you need
to come to the understanding that
there's no longer a single pillar of web
performance right up until now we've
really been talking about networking
load time right this has been the
currency that we've all traded amongst
our web developer brethren as the metric
of performance on our sites Hey Dude how
fast does your website load dude two
seconds dude high five anybody do that
no one okay
maybe I'm in the wrong room okay but
really what we've been seeing is that we
have how web apps have developed in the
need and the what users
demanded from our web applications have
brought these other two the next one is
render line is stood on stage today and
said that rendering is a performance
problem on mobile right now and we need
to fix that and guess what now we
finally have tools that allow you as the
developer to take control of your
rendering performance figure out the
problems that actually address them
right and then of course the final one
is compute network render and compute
compute has been one of sort of this the
Brethren of network over time JavaScript
performance you see it over and over
again nowadays VMs are so fast and so
powerful you generally don't see that of
course once you put it on a mobile
device and you get slower compute speed
you know you may run into some problems
so I generally hate doing this I hate
standing on stage and I hate telling you
go fix these three things but today I'm
gonna make an exception because I'm
particularly bold and angry today and I
figure I can get away with stuff when I
do that so here is your hit list we like
to joke in the perf squad that there's a
hit list right like if we had a
performance assassin on your team and he
needed to take out three things these
would be it so under the networking list
you should be optimizing critical path
right and this has I know this is the
tip of the iceberg question we'll get
into that in a minute for the render
list reduce your number of paints and
for compute reduce JavaScript execution
time these are the things if you come
away with nothing from this talk other
than that angry bald man yells loudly
come away with these three things right
this is where you need to focus your
performance time now what we're gonna do
for the rest of the talk here is we're
gonna talk a little bit about where
these things come from and how we can
dive in to diagnose them so let's start
with Network load time right again this
is where we've been unfortunately the
load times are really bad bad term right
measuring your performance of your
network speed via load time is like
measuring your cholesterol by how many
doughnuts you ate today right it's an
insanely complex procedure with many
dependent parts working together right I
mean this is just one spec for timing on
just getting data off the wire
it doesn't even talk about rendering or
anything else so we actually have to
change your vocabulary a little bit here
and we can actually probably use a
better term which is critical path right
so it's not just about loading it's
about what pixels are needed to get to
the screen so basically you have a
mobile device and it's it's kind of
waiting around right you the user types
in some information that goes sent off
to the inter tubules amongst all the
cats and and everything else out there
and it requests a site the site of
course is then going to return some sort
of markup form now what's gonna happen
here is that your page says cool I've
got HTML let me go start parsing all
this stuff so that I can start painting
unfortunately the web isn't that way
anymore all the content isn't just
contained in your HTML it's actually a
complex dance of other resources and so
we can't actually build our HTML to
start rendering yet instead we have to
wait for all of these other dependencies
to get resolved this is the critical
path if you haven't heard this term
before this is the critical path it's
the resolution of the dependencies of
your assets to get the first pixel on
your screen right because if you have
JavaScript that you're loading that's
going to affect how the Dom exists or
the CSS classes that's got to be present
if you've got 50 CSS classes that's got
to be present right so this is what you
need to optimize is the number of
dependencies in your critical path and
this really comes from 2 to 3 places the
first one is that once we put out a
request like this you've got a lot of
dependencies to other resources the
number of requests that you send out
there actually has an implicit overhead
for each one of them which even gets
worst on mobile devices right when
you've got a 3G network radio that's
spinning up and going through cell
towers and all sort of other arcane
magical technologies that existed back
in the caveman days you know that we
still have in our pocket oddly enough
you know that has overhead associated
with it so the more requests you're
doing the additional fat you're adding
to your time for each one of those
requests so if you're looking at this
you need to say okay one of our first
things we need to do is reduce the
number of requests we're doing to get
assets which kind of comes back to the
fact that you have to reduce the
complexity of asset dependency on your
page I see some people sleeping do I
need to clap kidding
I like that who did that you get a
t-shirt afterwards I will everyone else
is like I'm clapping now free stuff
let's go to the second one here right so
once you've actually got those requests
out on the wire the next problem is sort
of page weight how fat are your assets
and so I've kind of done a lot of study
in this over the past couple of months
about compression on the web anyone read
my series compression on the web more
yes I saw one dude like throw up the
tens in the background
you dude to t-shirts so the problem here
the problem here is that a lot of us are
still making content for our website as
though you have sort of a cable internet
connection when the reality is that 3G
kind of sucks line is stood on the stage
and said that earlier today right we
have assets that are too large if your
assets are too large and the number of
dependencies you have are too large of
course that's going to keep your
critical path from being resolved right
so look at it from a perf matter side of
it reduce the number of requests and
reduce the size of the total number of
requests so what happens here is this is
that once we get all of this done we can
finally get to a point that we can build
our DOM and our cssom or our render tree
and then we can resolve this chaos and
actually finally start painting the page
so the question for you then is if all
of this chaos is going onto the hood
that I have no idea about how do I use
my tooling to find it so let's take a
look at that really quick so this is the
verge it's a website it does some things
I'm not going to go too deep into that
but most of you already in the in the
the audience here know the network tab
right so I've got the verge set up here
it's actually loading the mobile site
we just hit reload here and you actually
see immediately what's going on now I
can dive deep deep deep into this tool I
think there's fantastic resources out
there that get that done better and I've
only got 30 minutes today so I'm going
to give you the high level in here right
so we're talking about reducing critical
path if you scroll keep scrolling scroll
all the way to the bottom here we see
this is about 90 requests to get this
site on the screen as well as 1.4 Meg
look it's not even done keep scrolling
down 1.4 Meg's of data okay now for a
mobile connection that's actually a lot
of data how many are you are in here
from Europe and other how many of you
are on roaming charges right now
round of applause if you hate that round
of applause if you'd like to see it less
than 1.5 max yeah it's okay we can take
time it's cool we got I love confusing
the audience they're like wait did we
did we really want to do that I don't
know and so the problem with this is
that all of this has to get down before
we can do anything and so this is
webpagetest.org hopefully you guys are
using this and if you run the verge
through webpagetest.org
you go down here into waterfall view and
you can see that this green line you
said already see this green line over
here yeah this green line represents
when the page painting occurs anything
before this green line represents
assets and dependencies that have to be
resolved before we can put a pixel on
the screen right so now look at this
what is this we keep scrolling down
looks like we've got maybe I'm just
gonna give it to him here and say about
60 assets that's 60 requests on the wire
I don't have the sizes of all of this
assets here but that's 60 requests that
had to go out there and get resolved
before I put a pixel on the screen let's
look at something that's a little bit
better granted it's a different example
but this is a my iord comm right all
props to Jake Archibald and so we just
hit reload here and was that one request
no there we go
this is this example is too good so you
can see as a very different pace this
version of the mobile site is actually
23 requests about 125 K right still able
to get to your data and I understand
there's a design principle difference
between these two sites but you want to
get it low and with the networking tab
you can figure this out when you look
over here at webpage test details you
can actually see that that green line
actually comes in at about 0.9 seconds
look at this we have maybe one to three
assets three assets that had to be
downloaded and resolved before the
critical path could start painting
that's the website you want your users
to load because that's where the money
is all right we're running out of time I
got a keeper in here so once you resolve
the chaos we get rendering or we get
networking done here's the thing I am I
am just the ghost of Christmas present
right like my job here is not to inform
you guys my job is to set up these brave
and awesome and smart gentlemen you more
information will be brought to you at
this conference from Ilya on performance
networking as well as Brian on creating
instant mobile web apps so now let's
talk about rendering right so we've got
a bunch of cat pictures we want to
deliver the cat pictures and a friendly
cat picture way because it's a cat
picture world that we live in and we
have to paint it so the cool thing is
that a lot of people didn't know until
earlier this year that painting on a
webpage was not free right so this is
actually a software resource something
has to happen so the user actually puts
his finger on your site and starts
scrolling around and what happens is we
have to translate the page and then
what's not visible to the page we have
to actually spin up the CPU and spend
cycles rasterizing that content okay and
this keeps occurring the user Scrolls we
have to rasterize content now there's a
there's a good talk you can see the link
on the bottom here we talk about the the
interdependency between the CPU and the
GPU
won't get in that today but the point
that you need to take away is that
scrolling isn't the only place that
painting occurs there's other things
that the user does that causes paints as
well for example let's say you have your
DOM and the Dom is doing awesome on its
Adame Dom day and the user clicks on
something you're like dude free stuff
and you have to actually pop up a dialog
to say dude free stuff right and in
doing so you modify the Dom well when
you modify the Dom all of the properties
of the Dom have to be recalculated
because we have to figure out did you
change something that was visible when
you do this we have to rebuild
everything which means things on the
screen of change which means we need to
actually repaint things so when you
change the Dom you update properties of
the Dom repaints have to occur another
great example right so let's say we've
got a user who's scrolling your site and
a lot of mobile web sites I see nowaday
use CSS properties to sort sort of store
state right so you've got some piece of
code here that's like hey the user is
scrolling now let's add this class to
the Dom that represents sticky we want a
sticky header right anyone do this you
don't have to read don't raise your hand
you're about to find out don't just
don't raise yet so the problem is every
time I'm giving you a warning
everything what's good is on the live
stream they can't see like this
directions they don't see this okay what
happens is every time you modify the
class list the CSS object model has to
be rebuilt and of course this causes a
repaint so you touch the Dom you touch
the SS repaints have to occur we call
this the paint storming if you get into
a weird cycle of this right so let's
take a look at the demo here single demo
this is super easy Paul Irish did a
fantastic video of this earlier this
year I just want to show what he did so
this is a scrolling a site okay and I'm
just kind of scrolling slowly here but
you can see it's actually just a little
jittery I'm not sure how well this is
coming on the stream but you can see
some of these white boxes here just
start moving - well and so when we hold
on
doing live demos is awesome if we
actually get recording on the timeline
here and start scrolling we can see sort
of a plethora of these green and purples
right and what we're effectively looking
at here is when you see green and
purples on the timeline view these are
recalc styles and layouts and this is
exactly what we were talking about we
have some event going on when you mouse
over them you get to go down here and
say hey here's the call stack that
caused this and lo and behold here is a
JavaScript function that's intermixed
between the jQuery that the user
developers of this website actually
wrote and you can see here basically
what they're doing let me see if I can
zoom that in just a little bit what
they're doing here is every time the
user Scrolls they're toggling a class
based upon some heuristic so every
single mouse scroll they're updating the
CSS tree which then has to be rebuilt
which then causes a repaint and we're
seeing this here in the timeline as well
right boom scroll recalculate layout
paint paint paint painting right and now
this this is really is pretty bad I mean
this is seven milliseconds on my desktop
here you know we get into some pretty
gnarly places where this is 10
milliseconds down here it looks like
we've got some big thick Purple's right
big thick perfect seven milliseconds
there rely on the Internet guys simmer
down simmer down so the point here is
that you can actually use the Timeline
view to find out what's causing these
recaps and and paints on your page so
one more info jank-free org these are
the jank Buster's these are the guys who
invented the term jank go follow them
they got to talk a little bit later Tom
will see us in NAT Duca they'll give you
all the details you need to make silky
smooth rendering performance so let's go
to my favorite area compute this is the
thing that I live and thrive on so let's
say 16 milliseconds of frame right you
got 60 frames a second means you have 16
milliseconds but the funny thing is you
don't have 16 milliseconds the browser
has 16 milliseconds you have to share
right remember your mom and your dad
taught you that when you're a kid like
hey you know you can't have your whole
time with the truck you got to trade the
truck with chrome you know chrome needs
time with the truck and then you can
have the truck back and you're like I
want my time and Chrome's like oh one
more time anyhow the point is that you
don't have fully 16 milliseconds to do
all your
you see when you get a RAF event chromes
doing other stuff right including that
other stuff is a paint event it actually
has to branch off and go do painting and
compositing and all this other stuff and
that's intermixed with all the
JavaScript that you're trying to run for
your application so what happens is
every 16 milliseconds you'll get a raft
pulse and this is fine until something
happens in your code that actually
pushes back this does it designated work
that Chrome's gonna do anyway right and
when that happens you miss that 16 frame
and your raft skips and this is known as
a skipped frame this is when users feel
jank
okay now I know we're talking about a
rendering problem in the compute section
but bear with me now so the question is
what caused that JavaScript to get slow
right we need to make sure that we keep
an eye on this 60 frames a second means
16 milliseconds of frame you have to
play nice share so let's say you've got
a cool game like a super resident raver
right and you're going along doing some
cool touch stuff right touch handler
occurs and you just do a flood of things
right the user touch so I need to go
through and order a pizza because I'm
hungry right now and update 10 million
zombies because they're gonna attack the
pizza and they're gonna be doing school
stuff too well the problem with this is
that you miss your raft target and of
course the next raft would want to come
immediately at that point but again it
has to skip a frame so the problem here
is that you end up doing too much work
in a single frame you can end up pushing
it back another problem is probably a
little bit more complex and I've done
some talks about this in the past but
let's say you've got just a ton of stuff
going on by the way if you if anyone
sends me source code of an html5 game
they make that implements all of those
guesses at once I will send you free
stuff I just want to put that out there
but let's say you've got like 90 hands
on a game right now and this is actually
causing a lot of allocations well what
can actually occur is that you during
your update phase right garbage
collection can occur anytime garbage
collection feels like it needs to occur
which can push out your update loop
because it needs time to go and it's a
single-threaded model right which is
then gonna put your draw back which
again is gonna put your raft back so
I've got a little bit of time here I
wanna I want to finish up on a high note
so actually not to Paul Lewis yet he's
bald okay so I want to show you what
this looks like so if you're trying to
track down performance issues from
compute here's super resident raper
there's two tools you need to check out
first off is collecting a JavaScript CPU
profile so I'm not gonna play the game
I'm just going to
sort of start here well okay maybe I'll
make some stuff happen okay things are
going yes good people running around
chaos ensues fantastic and I'm gonna let
that dude run around and get eaten by
zombies for a second but well you can
actually see down here and this is one
of my favorite things added to chrome
dev tools is this is a flame chart which
effectively shows me where all of my
calls are going for a given game or
given frame so I can actually see hey
wait a minute
where is my time going in my frame who's
responsible for it what's the function
that's taking that time this allows me
again to measure where my content is
going and updated in accordingly the
second thing you need to look at when
you're dealing with memory issues is
actually this record heap allocations
now for html5 game developers this is
fantastic because you can Jenna just hit
start and sit back now for those of you
who aren't versed in this tool it's
actually fantastic because it sort of
melds heap allocation tracking with a
Timeline view so what you're seeing at
the top there is allocations that have
been allocated and freed right some of
them are still resident on the stack you
can see that in blue some of them have
been freed and you can see that in gray
right and then you can find a specific
portion here then actually drill down
and say hey wait a minute what was
actually created during that frame to
create those allocations and if you're
lucky sometimes you can actually figure
out you know where in your code it
actually came from right so here I can
see that the fade timer string was
actually created it was probably passed
off to some anonymous function that
needed work done to it so with all of
these tools you kind of start getting
the sense that you can actually measure
what's going on in your mobile universe
you can actually get to the data you can
actually figure out what's going on take
ownership of your website performance
and before it I love this quote by Paul
Lewis tools not rules anyone who stands
on the stage at this point well okay
let's let's roll back for a minute you
know about a year and a half ago people
would give sort of performance advice
but there wasn't enough information on
the client-side to actually give that
advice right like hey your scrolling is
slow well how I don't know I kind of
tossed some chicken bones around and it
said it was slow so chicken bones right
but now we have tools and now you need
to move towards that methodology
validate everything you're seeing
measure it go forward with that
methodology don't just rely on a bunch
of bald people standing you on stage
telling you what to optimize go find it
in your tool chain in your application
and fix it there my name is Colton
go to html5rocks if you want to become a
performance guru check out the slides
and the other talks we've been talking
about today here's how you get ahold of
me
perf matters thank you for your time
today appreciate it